(crowd clapping)
- All right, everybody.
Let's dip into the world
of social media before we go,
this is What I'm Liking.
(crowd clapping)
All right, the big game is this Sunday.
And all week we are sharing great stories
to get you focused on football,
'cause it's incredible.
As a Cowboys fan, it's not so incredible.
(crowd laughs)
I'm still devastated
that we lost the wildcard game.
It's fine.
But this video put a smile on my face.
And more than a smile,
I laughed hysterically.
I almost peed my pants.
A wife recorded her husband,
'cause we are these, I am this husband.
A wife recorded her
husband watching that loss
and his reactions were so predictable,
she created a bingo drinking game,
marking the squares as he stressed out.
Take a look.
(upbeat game music)
(fan grunting)
(crowd cheering)
This is my favorite
What I'm Liking.
Because I have never related more.
I don't know if you could see it,
but my favorite is the square
that says aggressively pets dog.
(crowd laughing)
Which I have completely
done to my poor Henry.
I've been like, oh my God.
Like, well he's got a lot of fur.
But we have that couple
on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to
Mackenzie and Justin,
watching on NBC five Dallas-Fort Worth.
What's up y'all?
(crowd cheers)
- Hi Kelly.
- So does he act this way for all games?
- Oh yes.
So, we've been watching
Cowboys games together
for about seven years now.
And he's been reacting the
same way for seven years.
You know, he yells the same things,
he uses the same gestures, he sits
in the exact same spot, and he even wears
the same exact thing every single game
because he is so superstitious.
- Yes.
- And you know,
now I have learned to love the Cowboys
and be a Cowboys fan.
And that's why I made this Bingo card.
- So Justin, you make
your own clothing, right?
Was that an outfit you made?
- Yeah, I actually made
those shorts in college.
I just made 'em as ridiculous as possible.
I actually have 'em right here.
I look about four feet
tall when I wear 'em.
And then we actually have a 1-year-old now
and so he got his own little pair.
- Yes!
(crowd awing)
- So, these are amazing.
- Oh my gosh!
- So he, yeah he gets
to join the very bitter,
bittersweet lifestyle of a Cowboys fan.
- Cowboy nation.
Yeah, there we go.
- Yeah, so he gets to watch the morning
and afternoon games with us.
And then for the nighttime games,
I actually wear a pair of oven mitts
so I can clap without waking him up, so...
(crowd laughs)
- Oh my god, I know.
'Cause the box that says quiet clap,
'cause anyone with kids knows that.
It's like yeah.
Oh my God, I love it so
much. It is so relatable.
Thank you so much Mackenzie.
You are hilarious.
Justin, keep wearing those shorts
or maybe don't 'cause
they're not good luck.
I don't know.
(crowd laughs)
I don't know. Let's
just try something new.
How about that, Cowboy nation?
- How about that?
- I'm loving
your post right now, I'm liking it.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise, the go-to
pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
sympathize with cowboy fans everywhere,
so they will be writing you a
check for a thousand dollars.
(crowd applauding)
- There you go.
- Oh my God, thank you so much.
- Awesome.
- Look Justin,
I'm gonna keep wearing my Cowboy onesie.
You keep wearing your shorts.
We're gonna get there.
Next season, next season guys.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you to all
our guests this hour, Dwayne Wade,
Callum Turner, Jay
Shetty, and Lawrence Gary.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, change it.